[Music]
found a couple more people talking about
the brandon shop thing and because i
think it's hilarious i thought we played
some it's friday anyway let's have some
fun spreading like wildfire yeah so uh
this was when um our buddy
louis j gomez was on uh tim dillon's
show
the great nick mullen uh i think we're
gonna do a state of the industry address
as bastard radio so the biggest topics
from the year we're going to break down
i just want to cover please
if we do a state of the industry address
we've got to carve out gringo poppy who
does
you notice how lewis is stirring all
this [ __ ] up of course he knows what
he's doing he's such a [ __ ] he knows
[ __ ] exactly what he's doing come on
i respect it i think it's hilarious
but i want to do l.a i want to do the i
said we just no no i want to do these
statements
why is tim not no tim say i want to hear
it stop sandbagging it tim yeah let's
hear it of the la podcasting oh yeah oh
okay actually this is pretty funny i
want to stay to the la podcast seems
pretty funny part of me as part of the
state of the industry addresses
skankfest yeah you and nick can do
everything else yeah everything else
that's yours you could never you you
guys cover all of new york television
and film every podcast in the world
other than and you could also comment on
the state of the la podcasting of course
of course but i would like to delete it
my
expertise i just want to do the state of
the la podcast scene the great enduring
scene that will never die can we and
it'll be called the la podcasting the
scene that will never die i would you
know what i would call it if you know
what i would call his segment
i would if i see tim this is what you do
be very funny call it gringo poppy
that that'll be the segment name just
call it the gringo poppy segment like
that would be
actionable
you really think he's going to cl he
claims everything he might brandon might
claim it jesus christ i think he's going
to claim it yeah he would he's already
gonna do sue a bunch of youtubers oh
he's doing that though marsh famously
and it will have the photos of the
people who are currently in prison
tim can we play word association la
comic scene sure all right uh-oh
uh-oh
ready
you should just fire it off don't be a
[ __ ] whitney cummings
drugs
[Laughter]
holy
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] man
drugs
bobby lee
korean
oh
he is accurate
i mean it's the first thing that comes
to mind brian cowan
russia you know that's he wanted to say
another r word it would have been funny
even though it would have been funny
though right
watch okay okay you do me the word
association ask me brian helen or brian
kelly rapist i'm kidding by the way
that's a joke i'm joking but
that's the joke right brennan shop
[ __ ]
all r words
gringo poppy
kind of
brilliant
kind of brilliant
he's being such an [ __ ] right now
kind of brilliantly brilliantly funny in
a way that no comedy special has ever
been
okay that's funny
like it's so brilliant it's meta it's a
moment that's it it's meta yeah yeah
yeah
it's like an early like it's like it's
like a it's like an early one of those
like uh david early david lynch films
it's an experimental it's an
experimental comedy special
because it's it's mysterious in a way
because you're looking at it and you're
going like there's a lot of choices made
and you don't know why those choices
were made
[Laughter]
can i say tim dylan is [ __ ] killing
me right now you know i'm starting to
get the impression
[Laughter]
look i'm not gonna sit here and pretend
like i know anything about the l.a
comedy scene right but
i'm getting the impression
that these people don't respect brendan
i don't think so no
maybe this is what brendan was watching
when he was crying on instagram
of course yeah the comedy store uh
fine
that's it i can't name another word i
mean that's you know yeah
well here's what's amazing about the
gringo poppy this is
what's truly amazing about it okay
you're watching it
and you're in kind of it's it's
you're in a little bit of disbelief
[Laughter]
i wouldn't use that word i'd be much
meaner but yes i hear what you're saying
honestly
tim dillon being nice is way meaner than
us being mean
right like it's just
because it is
i i wonder and i know he's trying to get
good at stand up and i respect the hell
out of that the question is what did it
have to be a special
you know what i'm imagining you know
those old trailers
where they say like the different
headlines gringo poppy does it have to
be a special tim dylan
yeah yeah oh yeah like when the movies
have like yeah endorsements yeah
crinkle bobby does it have to be a
special tim dillon
why louis j gomez
who joe rogan
leonard malton says
why
that's the real question no
no it didn't yeah and i'm not one of
these guys like there's nothing like
this that's not [ __ ] he's like a nice
guy and i know he's trying to be you
know like but the question is with that
particular thing you go did that have to
be
i said this on real-life podcast not
only does it need to be didn't need to
be a special gentleman
gentlemen not only didn't need to be a
special
it took him five
five takes to get that 26 minutes of
gold you saw
five
he should have friends going because
here's the thing he's a charming dude
right yes
disagree
um and he i think
i don't know at all you know but i think
there's probably something he's probably
a funny he probably makes his friends
laugh right
can i agree can i agree with louis
though
he probably doesn't make his friends
laugh
but i don't think it's because he's
funny
trust me right now all his friends are
laughing at him they laugh a lot more
when he's not in the room yeah
yeah i think that he's really great at
podcasting on that specific show for
that on for a specific hour about one
specific topic and a specific co-host if
it's only about mma and if it's only on
a tuesday but only if it's overcast
tim dillon's about to go look bro i'm
gonna compliment him right now like i i
think his knowledge of food trucks is
unparalleled
you know everybody knows uh everybody
knows ufc fighters make better comedians
because they have a a higher a higher
brain bone
and then louie's like yeah no seriously
doggy like i mean i've never met anybody
that knows as much about street tacos
arm bars and street tacos doggy that's
the name of the show arm bars and street
tacos are you kidding me you named the
show there you go that should be a show
arm bars and street tacos it'll be a
show with brendan shop and thunderosa
right
no think about it isn't it perfect
the hardpartisan street tacos man she's
already having problems getting over
let's not make her career any worse
i've heard she doesn't have a problem
getting under that audience wait whoa
what huh i didn't say anything
is that a thing hey no it's anything to
talk off the air okay there's an
audience of people in america that want
what he does and he does it for them i
am not that audience of course
because you have eyeballs and ears tim
not comedy
but that's fair but that's fair and
here's the thing yeah we the
the most fun thing for me with this with
this newest because we we were making
let's put it this way we were making fun
of brendan shaw before it was cool and
i'm not saying we were the first ones a
lot of people like base frequency is a
great example but so people have been
making fun of brandon job for it's
not pretending it was us but we were
making fun of him before it was cool we
were making fun of him when there was a
backlash for it right but now i think
one of the funniest things is
i'll tell you this and i will never say
who it is okay
but marshall remember
we were we were talking about brennan
chubb and brandon shaw but
he's talked [ __ ] about a lot of other
comedians right like we've played clip
after clip after clip right
it was one of those times he was talking
[ __ ] about one of those comedians and
you know we called out chopper but not
being as funny or whatever whatever
whatever
so somebody dm me
and all they dm me
was a was a winky face
and that's it because nobody wants
you know
to go on record on pape back then
making fun of
brendan but now what i like is we're
getting to that point where
watching comedians
when a special is so bad right
that comedians who normally defend each
other they have to bash it or they lose
they are now but but but the way they're
bashing it is is so
passive aggressive
i wanted to say precise
it's it's very they're making if there's
a lot of like yeah you know it [ __ ]
suck but he's a nice guy going on you
know there's a [ __ ] suck but he's a
nice guy
did that have to be i said this on real
last podcast he should have friends
going because here's the thing he is a
charming dude right yes um and he i
think
i don't know at all
very rare yeah very rare and you see it
and you're like god damn dude those guys
got good and they got good fast and they
started getting things i was pretty rare
i got pretty good pretty quickly but
again
you took it humble tim
humility
and now he's a
[Music]
he's a jester gay man when you watch
especially he's like
and you go what why
what is this disease maybe they should
come out next week what is it
you're six foot six you're an adonis you
could beat up 99 of the people
[ __ ] women and you don't have to [ __ ]
these skanks at the comedy store
[Laughter]
well
you know what earlier i was saying they
were being very nuanced about it
remember when you were saying it was
remember when you're saying it was being
passive aggressive i think i was just
aggressive
moved on to just aggression
[ __ ] hot women
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you and he
instead he's
only gay what is wrong with you
on stage in dallas in front of 45 people
being like the line
is that my door
it's just
he did the voice the law the mountain
lion's at my door
they're citing specific parts which
means bro you're gonna [ __ ] tell me
that these guys probably have it all sat
together at some one of these friends
houses and just [ __ ] watched it over
and over and over again you know they
did because these people know everything
in this [ __ ] thing way better than i
do
it's puzzling
it's uh yeah you don't need it when you
don't need it but that's the thing like
um
you know i i don't i i i feel yeah
no no me saying you shouldn't be a
comedian is the highest respect i can
pay you
i don't think so if you want to be a
comic
right
if if i look at you and go you shouldn't
really do comedy it's me going
you are better than this i truly believe
he's like better than this
that's quite a sp what is he better in
what way though is what i don't
understand right in what way is he
better you know he can't still be a
fighter because he can bench press more
probably that's true we all know until
you start to do this this was nobody's a
plan nobody no i was in a little kid
being like dude i want to [ __ ] dance
like a monkey for strangers right and
and pray to god that they like me and
that they react to my words in a club
yes or i won't feel anything that's
happiness
for my happiness so everyone knows their
happiness is inconsequential in this
means nothing like what people say to me
they're like your podcast got me through
the quarantine i'm like you have no idea
what it's done for me
uh
look he's not i will agree with making
fun of it but i do definitely do not
agree with he's bet no he's not in what
way
better in what way at kicking yeah
uh this is one more i think when
i think lewis was all with stevo i
thought this was funny it's made me just
made me laugh i should be a lie detector
test on the show like a fbi grade lie
detector test and we asked him if he
regretted the kobe tweet and he said no
and he was not lying
he did not regret it at all i mean that
was like and then the the we also asked
him if he found brendan trump funny and
he said yes and that was a lie
louis is just not letting it go man like
he's wearing he's wearing a zakamiko
shirt
okay i doubt that i saw that's cause
all the gas digital people are like aew
wrestlers they wear each other's shirts
yeah to help get each other over
um
like punk wearing an ftr shirt
so
this one is this is i want i left this
at the end of the for the shop segment
because
this is him talking about when he got a
billboard okay
and now you want me to ask why people
don't like him listen to this 28 seconds
of audio
the billboard is such a flex dude
has it equal i think it's cool has it
equaled any views is anybody driving on
hollywood boulevard like holy [ __ ]
no no i literally did it just for other
comics like all these guys promised you
this yeah i did it myself man like
sir
sir
yes yes yes
yeah what's wrong how dare you
he did it him he grinded
grinding
you five takes you use your old ufc
money to buy a billboard yeah
it's not like you made the money in
comedy no
call me
call me thank you
no no i literally did it just for other
comics like all these guys promised you
this yeah i did myself man like check
this out it's a complete waste of money
i literally did it just for other comics
like all these guys promised you this
yeah i did myself man like check this
out by the way buttons
does he think that
like
does he think that this is going to make
him likable no no he i think he thinks
he's likable but he's not
by the way in the chat uh
somebody said something pretty funny
about
now i can't see it so but somebody said
he's right you can rent a billboard
oh no that's the fallen waffle said
though he's not wrong you can rent a
billboard he's right he's right now i'm
wrong
and sometimes the billboard is just fly
off why don't we get a billboard because
it's stinky he's just stinky no we
should get a billboard we should we
should get we should get one across the
street from the gringo poppy no no no no
no no heal me out
our pictures but the same exact
billboard it still says the gringo poppy
poppy yeah it's just us on honest yeah
that's it that way he has to drive bite
and go
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
he'll sue us because he has lawyers that
he's paying with his ufc money
because that's the other thing a lot of
people are like
what if we get a billboard picture of
brendan schaub on it and it says dana
white [ __ ] this guy's girlfriend well
would that be that'd be funny
and probably true um look the the thing
the thing is with this is like i
understand what comics are like look i
don't want to insult anybody else's
comedy and i get that but the other side
of it is is like this isn't about making
fun of his comment anymore like this is
now he's he's like suing youtubers you
know what i mean like suing youtubers
and bragging about billboards and now
he's dunking on him right right and he's
and he also he was also said he was
gonna
send bobby lee to jail for being a
hacker like we're not talking about this
isn't making fun of his bad special yes
his special was bad but it's because
he acts out and he just goes after
people and
and bet pixels takes videos down like
they haven't gone after our videos again
i guess [ __ ] we beat him so many
times what are you gonna do you know
but i i
am really really getting [ __ ] sick of
you people a lot of you people think
that it's because of the comedy the co
yes brennan is fun to laugh at that's
what this all started with but now he's
just being a [ __ ] jerk you know
be a real jerk
and that concludes our brandon shop
segment
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you